welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to this episode we're covering the
2019 adaptation of Pet Sematary
the film is packed with hidden meanings
changes to the source material and
Easter eggs that hint to the larger King
universe and throughout this video I'll
be breaking down everything that you
need to know about the movie's plot and
ending this is full spoilers ahead so if
you haven't seen the movie yet and don't
want to know what happens then I highly
recommend that you turn off now make
sure you stick around until the end of
the video for my review of the film and
leave your thoughts in the comments if
you agree or disagree with me without
the way thanks for clicking the video
and let's dive into my ending explain
breakdown of Pet Sematary Pet Sematary
opens with the Creed family home in
ruins and instantly the film lets you
know that this isn't going to have a
happy ending this sets the tone for the
movie going forward and we flash back to
the Creed's driving to their new family
home located on the outskirts of the
forest in Ludlow isn't it weird how most
horror movies start with a family
driving somewhere you've got us The
Shining the Evil Dead the next time you
want to go somewhere just stop the car
turn around and go back
anyway the Creed's are made up of father
Lewis mother Rachel daughter Ellie son
gage and cat Church who may I just say
is the best actor in this entire film
throughout the film we learn that rachel
is haunted by the death of her sister
who suffered from a degenerative spinal
disease that twisted her bones and left
her bed bound Rachel's sister Zelda used
to taunt her by saying that one day she
too would get the disease and his
terrified her to the point that she was
too scared to take food up to her room
one day when Rachel was left alone with
her she sent food up in a dumbwaiter
however the lift broke and Zelda tried
to climb in to get it
causing the elevator to collapse and
killing herself in the process rachel
lives with the guilt of this accident
and has been psychologically scarred to
the point that she is unable to discuss
death open
the death of Rachel's sister and Zelda's
clear dislike for her sets up the motif
of a deceased family member coming back
to haunt the one who caused their death
and this plays into the film's ending
heavily which I'll get into later anyway
the kree's led Nia an extremely
dangerous Road that large semi trucks
often speed along with little regard for
the homes that peppered the road there's
a lot of foreshadowing of this and Creed
who is an ER doctor one day has a
patient rushed into his surgery that has
been hit by a car on campus grounds the
patient named Victor is pretty mangled
with his bones and brains hanging out
and unfortunately he passes away due to
his injuries lewis is haunted by victor
who seems to be trying to warn him not
to break the barrier between the living
and dead this highlights that
spiritually the town has something up
with it and there's ghosts throughout
that kind of horn the characters on
Halloween Lewis finds his dead cat by
the side of the road and with advice
from jarred his neighbor he decides not
to tell his daughter instead informing
her that the cat merely ran away Jody
who has grown close to Ellie tells Lewis
that they should bury the cat at night
and in the dark hours of the morning the
two venture up to the pet cemetery
located in the woods near the home
should it desperate not to see Ellie's
heartbroken by the death tells Lewis of
a place further in the forest and the to
go there and buried the cat the next day
Church returns and after getting some
bad cattitude from him
Lewis finds out that the ground is a
place located on sacred Native American
lands you can't say Indian burial ground
anymore so don't even think it you're
racist
anyway this land is used to bring back
the dead and a Wendigo is said to horn
there and the Native Americans ended up
having to move because the ground went
sour now we never see the Wendigo but
there's definitely something there that
can be heard moving in the dark and it's
altogether pretty creepy for those who
don't know the Wendigo is a major
villain in Stephen King's the girl who
loved Tom Gordon and also the
novelization of Pet Sematary
the Wendigo is a demon worshiped by
Native American tribes and it's steeped
in King's work and in the girl who loved
Hon Gordon a family that go hiking or
run into the creature if that book is
ever adapted I can definitely see you
picking up with the Wendigo from this
film
anyway back at home Ellie begins locking
her doors at night so church can get in
and when Lewis finds the cat engages
crib about to attack him he decides that
Dead is
we better lewis goes to put the cat down
but after a gibson puss-in-boots eyes he
decides to take it far up the road and
leave it there are some warning signs
here not to trespass and this could
perhaps hint that there are the part in
the area that have been purposely
cordoned off due to their ability to
raise the dead anyway life seems to
return to normal for the family and they
throw a ninth birthday party for Ellie
who still misses her cat I'm playing
hide and seek she runs near the road and
after seen walking down it decides to
run out in the middle of it gage follows
her but he clearly does engage the
situation well and Lewis has to run into
the road to save him now this is where
the movie differs slightly from the
original and source material as in that
it was gage who died whereas here it's
le overall I think it's actually a
better choice to have le die as they do
some fantastic make-up effects with her
and with her being slightly older she's
able to talk more and be more of a
threatening force anyway le is killed
they hold a funeral and Rachel engage go
to stay at her parents Lewis aware that
Jude will try to stop him if he brings
Ellie back goes over to his house Cordy
bees him and takes Ellie up to the pet
cemetery where she returns in the dead
of night clearly she's messed up but
Lewis looks past it due to the grief
Rachel engaged drive home and passed
through dairy which some King fans may
recognize in case you don't dairy is the
town in which Pennywise the clown lives
and it's the setting of it so this is a
nice little reference to the larger King
world anyway Rachel drives home
horrified at her daughter's return and
Lewis leaves the house to discover that
Jude has been murdered by Ellie they do
an awesome fake out on the Achilles heel
stabbed before bringing it back and fans
of the original will love this callback
at this time Ellie has went into full
rampage mode and she's able to catch him
mother off-guard
due to her psychosis and believing that
her sister Zelda is haunting her le
murders her mother but rachel is able to
pass gage out to Lewis locks him in the
car in order to keep him safe Ellie
knocks Lewis out and drags her mother up
to the pet cemetery and on her return
from burying her is attacked by Lewis
who attempts to kill her but hesitates
when she tells him that they can still
be a family it's at this point that
Lewis has stabbed through the back by a
reanimated Rachel and a to drag his body
up to the cemetery to bring him back to
life the film ends with the darkest King
finale since the mist with the Family
Circle engage in the car before
unlocking it
probably murder him and bring him back
as the undead obviously there's a lot to
take from this personally I think the
movie is a commentary on how grief can
cause us to do out of character things
that have the potential to lead to our
home demise the family in the film are
destroyed due to their inability to
accept death and ultimately this leads
to their downfall they should be
embracing all aspects of life but
instead they only want the things that
suit them and in the end this causes
them to become part of the undead Rachel
cannot accept that she caused her
sister's death and the shielding from
the truth throughout the film causes the
family's downfall this is about
accepting life and no matter how short
as a beautiful thing and not trying to
subvert it in order to get our own
twisted view of what reality should be
as mentioned earlier the film has
several major differences from the book
and in that it's gauge who is killed and
resurrected the film also makes no
mention of the last person who was
resurrected by the burial ground Timmy
beggarman after beta man was buried he
came back as a malevolent zombie and
terrorized the town folk before they
tracked him down and killed him in the
book Joe believed that a demon had
possessed the corpse as when attempting
to kill it they a mentor knit them with
indiscretions from their personal lives
whilst there are hints that Elie is
possessed by something this is never
fully confirmed in the book Lewis
returns to the burial ground with Rachel
after gage kills her under the notion
that if he buries her faster than gage
something better will happen
however it's hinted that this doesn't
change a thing and upon her return there
is definitely a sinister side to it
Lewis also kills gage with a lethal
injection whereas in the film the family
are still alive if you can call it that
and now on to my review okay so the
first question you may have is is this
better than the original film well
you'll be happy to hear that I think it
surpasses the 1989 film in pretty much
every way the atmosphere is creepier the
acting is a lot better and the narrative
changes definitely elevate the plot and
make more
the second question that you may have is
is this better than it unfortunately not
at least in my opinion whilst the
narrative is a lot better the lack of a
true villain here really makes it less
engaging for me than it was it feels
rather run-of-the-mill story wise and
the movie misses out on certain chances
to improve on the self containment of
the original story those who've seen the
trailer will probably know the majority
of the plot beats here and it's strange
that so much was spoiled in the
promotional material for the film there
are also certain plot points like
Rachel's sister that don't really have
any impact beyond being in the
characters heads and this feels like a
slightly missed opportunity the film is
still very enjoyable oh and it's
definitely worth checking out in cinemas
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on Pet Sematary and if you prefer this
version or the original comment below
and let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my breakdown of the
Twilight zones new episodes which would
be linked at the end this is the channel
for people who were mad into movies so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best I'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]